اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى ساعه اخباريه جديده
من العربيه نتابع فيها تطورات المشهد في
السودان وايضا تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا
وهذه هي العناوين
دوي انفجارات في الخرطوم وتجدد للشبكات
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في
محيط المطر
الامم المتحده تكشف عن مفاجاه مقتل وجرحي
سبعه اطفال كل ساعه بسبب الاقتتال في
السودان
ومن اخبارنا ايضا
بالرد على استهداف الكريملين ويتهمفيد
الهجوم بضوء اخضر غربي
وسجل يتجدد من جديد بين قاده روسيا
العسكريين قائد بجناري يهدد بالانسحاب من
بخمت والسبب نقص الذخيره
[موسيقى]
ما انسى الهدوء في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم حتى تجدد القصف في انفجارات دوت
واشتباكات اندلعت بين قوه الدعم السريع
والجيش رغم الهدنه ودعوه التهدئه فيما
شوهدت اعمده الدخان في محيط منطقه مطار
منطقه الخرطوم وسمعت اصوات المضادات
الارضيه بمناطق عده شرق العاصمه ومع
استمرار المواجهات يزداد الضغط على القطاع
الصحي وزير الصحه السودانيه قال ان
الامدادات الطبيه تتاثرت بشكل كبير من
الاقتتال الحاصل
قبل ذلك اكد الدعم في بيان قبوله تمديد
الهدنه لمده 72 ساعه بواسطه سعوديه
امريكيه والالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار كما
اعلن الدعم السريع الترحيبه بالمبادرات
المحليه والاقليميه والدوليه لوقف اطلاق
النار بهدف فتح ممرات انسانيه وتسهيل حركه
المواطنين
ومع استمرار خلق الهدنه في السودان اعلن
الجيش السوداني في بيان له عن احباط هجوم
لقوات الدعم السريع على مدينه الابيض
بشمال كردفان حيث توجد ثاني اكبر حاميه
عسكريه في البلاد وفرض سيطره كامله على
المدينه واوضح البيان ان قوه من الجيش
اشتبكت مع الدعم السريع وكبدتهم خسائر
كبيره في الارواح مع تدمير 30 مركبات
واضاف الجيش السوداني ان الدعم السريع
هجوما على معسكر تدريب في جبل كردفان اسفر
عن مقتل 15 عسكريا بينهم اثنان من الضباط
كما لاحقت مجموعات من الهجانه التابعه
للجيش عناصر الدعم السريع في عدد من شوارع
وازقه المدينه وفق البيان
وينضم الينا من الخرطوم الزميل سالم
الهاشمي مراسل العربيه مرحبا بك سالم
مجددا تتجدد الاشتباكات يعود التوتر بشكل
كبير الى العاصمه الخرطوم ما هي اخر
التطورات
نعم تجددت الاشتباكات اليوم بشكل اخر وهذه
المره في مناطق متفرقه من العاصمه الخرطوم
ربما ايضا هنالك اشتباكات في مناطق بالقرب
من القصر الجمهوري وليست ببعيده كذلك من
مطار الخرطوم الدولي اخر التطورات على
الارض كذلك هناك حريق هائل في منطقه قريبه
من مول عفراء وهذا المول هو ليس ببعيد من
مطار الخرطوم الدولي وبالقرب من الساحه
الخطره يقع جنوبي مطار قرب من الساحه
الخطره يقع جنوبي مطار الخرطوم الدولي قبل
ساعتين من الان تقريبا في بقيه المدن كذلك
بحري وام درمان هنالك اشتباكات وهجمات
تقوم بها القوات الجويه السودانيه على
المناطق التي تتمركز بها قوات الدعم
السريع وتواجد القوات في هذه المناطق هذه
الاشتباكات تجددت مره اخرى رغم الهدنه
المعلنه ما يفهم منه انه ليس هنالك هدنه
حتى الان
ماذا عن نتائج للشبكات على الارض ماذا عن
الضحايا ماذا عن التعامل الانساني والطبي
مع ما حدث
نعم يصعب الحديث عن تفاصيل ما حدث بعد ذلك
لان هذه المناطق يصعب الاقتراب منها كذلك
والتصوير في هذه المناطق التي اصبحت هي
مناطق تتجدد فيها الاشتباكات دائما وهي
اصبحت من المناطق الخطره كذلك بالنسبه
للمواطنين عطفا على ما ذكره الجيش
السوداني بانه يجب الابتعاد عن المناطق
التي تتجدد فيها الاشتباكات حفاظا على
الارواح ما يفهم منه ما يفهم منه ان هذه
المنطقه اصبحت منطقه عمليات كصعب الاقتراب
منها ومعرفه تفاصيلها لكن على الوضع
الانساني بشكل عام ما زالت الحياه متوقفه
بالنسبه للمواطنين فيما يتعلق بحياتهم
اليوميه ما زالت تتوقف كل عمليات الامداد
بشكل شبه كامل لكثير من السلع وكذلك
المحروقات كذلك توقف الجهاز المصرفي وهذه
من الامور التي يتحدث عنها المواطنون في
الاماكن البعيده من مناطق الاشتباكات هنا
في ولا عدم توفر السيوله وكذلك التطبيقات
البنكيه فيها اعطاب كثيره جدا
ومتعثره كذلك ما يجعل الحياه قاسيه بالفعل
للمواطنين حتى بعيدا عن مناطق الاشتباكات
سالم ما الذي يحدث على الارض هل هناك
محاولات مثلا من طرف بعينه لاستعاده نفوذ
الطرف الاخر على الارض ام ماذا يحدث
على الارض تتجدد هذه الاشتباكات كل يوم
تقوم القوات الجويه السودانيه بقصف
المناطق التي تتمركز بها قوات الدعم
السريع
وتشن هذه الغارات على طول النهار باوقات
متقطعه واحيانا بشكل متواصل على فترات
طويله في المناطق التي تتمركز بها هذه
القوات في هذه اللحظات نستمع الى عزيز
الطائره من طائرات القوات الجويه
السودانيه وربما هي طائره استكشاف واحيانا
تكون هنالك الطائرات التي تقوم باستهداف
المواقع التي تتمركز بها قوات الدعم
السريع ونحن نعلم ان انتشار هذه القوات في
طرق كثيره جدا بقرب مطار الخرطوم وكذلك
بالقرب من القصر الرئاسي وبالقرب من
القياده العامه للجيش وايضا في احياء
سكنيه كذلك ليست ببعيده من هذه المناطق
مثل الخرطوم اثنين وغيرها من المناطق في
هذه المناطق تتمركز هذه القوات
وتقوم بارتكازات كذلك في تلك الشوارع ربما
هذه
الذي تقوم به القوات الجويه السودانيه هي
مساله
ضرب هذه القوات
والابتعادها من هذه المناطق على الاقل ومن
ثم تتعامل معها القوات البريه اذا لا هدنه
الان في السودان وخاصه في الخرطوم
نعم لا وجود اليهود على الارض الان
الاشتباكات ما زالت متواصله لكنها بوتيره
احيانا اعلى واحيانا اقل تختلف من ساعه
لاخرى لكنها الان هناك شبه هدوء عدا هذه
الطائرات التي يسمع عزيزها بين الفينه
والاخرى زميلي سالم الهاشمي مراسل العربيه
من الخرطوم شكرا لك على كل هذه المعلومات
اعلنت شبكه الاتصالات ام تي ان توقف
خدماتها في الخرطوم عن العمل وذلك بسبب
توقف مقسمات الشركه في الخرطوم عن العمل
ما ادى لانقطاع جميع الخدمات عن المشتركين
جراء انقطاع الامداد الكهربائي اقلت
الشركه انها تعمل على استعاده خدماتها
وايجاد حلول باقرب وقت
هذا وقال وزير الماليه السودانيه جبريل
ابراهيم في بيان له حول جهود مجلس الوزراء
اذا الوضع الحالي في السودان قال ان مجلس
الوزراء يبذل كل الجهود مع اطراف الصراع
لتوفير المواد التموينيه والوقود في
البلاد مشيرا الى تشكيل لجنتين من قبل
المجلس موضحا ان لجنه الاولى خاصه
بالطوارئ الانسانيه والثانيه مختصه
بمتابعه ثياب السلع والخدمه اللازمه شدد
ابراهيم في البيان على اهميه فتح ممرات
امنه لوصول الكوادر الطبيه وغيرهم من
الموظفين لمباشره اعمالهم
هذا وتتواصل وتداعيات الحرب الدائره بين
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع حيث لقى شاب
وطفله مصرعهما في مدينه ام درمان وجرح
خمسه اخرين اثر سقوط مقذوف على منزل بحي
الشرفيه امس الاول نحن الان نتواجد في
مدينه ام درمان تحديدا حي الشرفيه لعكس
احدى التداعيات الانسانيه جراء هذه
الاشتباكات المسلحه بين قوات الدعم السريع
تحديدا في حي الشرفيه سقطت قذيفه في هذه
المنطقه تماما وهذه اثار الشظايا على هذا
الباب وعلى هذه السيارات التي ادت الى
مقتل اثنين احداهما طفله والاخر شاب بعمر
السادسه والعشرين وكذلك ادت الى جرح خمسه
اخرين جميعهم الان يتلقون العلاج واحدهم
يتاثر بجراح بجراحه البالغ وكذلك ادت الى
انقطاع السلك الضغط العالي للكهرباء الذي
كذلك بمجهودات
شعبيه من
المواطنين ومن المهندسين في غرفه الطوارئ
هنا في ام درمان والذي شهيد الحمد لله
اه يا حمودي
لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله
الله يرضي الله انا لله وانا اليه راجعون
انا لله وانا اليه راجعون زي ما حرقوا
قلبي الله يحرق قلوبهم ولدي شافي عيش
شبابه الحمد لله الحمد لله
في حي الشرفيه
[موسيقى]
واسرة طائشه ماما مصدره ايه
شايفين
واننا جيران برضو مصابين لا عندنا قرش لا
عندنا تعاليم ولا عندنا اي حاجه والله
قطعته معايشنا والله العظيم
احنا تعبانين جدا جدا
هذا وحضرت منظمه الصحه العالميه ومنظمه
الامم المتحده لطفوله يونيسيف من ان
المعارك الدائره في السودان منذ ثلاثه
اسابيع تحصد ارواح اطفال باعداد كبيره
مرعبه مشيره الى ان التقارير تفيد بسقوطه
سبعه اطفال كل ساعه بين قتيل وجريح كما
افادت المنظمه الامميه بمقتل 190 طفلا
واصابه 1700 اخرين بجروح خلال او خلال اول
احد عشر يوما فقط من القتال مشيره الى ان
هذا يعني ان هذه الارقام لا تغطي سوى
الاطفال الذين وصلوا الى مرافق الرعايه
الصحيه في تلك المناطق ومحذره من ان
الواقع قد يكون اسوا بكثير
هذا وطلبت مفوضيه الامم المتحده للاجئين
الدول المستقبله للاجئين السودانيين بعدم
اعادتهم الى بلادهم بسبب الصراع كما افادت
بياناته المفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده
لشؤون اللاجئين بان اخر الاحصائيات
الوارده من وزاره الخارجيه المصريه تظهر
تدفق اكثر من 56 الف شخص الى البلاد فرارا
من صراع السودان حتى الرابع من مايو الجري
ووفقا لمكتب المفوضيه فان من بين هؤلاء
الاشخاص الذين دخلوا البلاد من معبري
ارقين وقسط ما لا يقل عن
52,500 سوداني ونحو 4000 من جنسيات اخرى
وينضم الينا من مدينه اسوان مراسل العربيه
الزميل احمد عثمان مرحبا بك احمد بالتاكيد
هناك ضغط كبير لاعداد كبيره من اللاجئين
في السودان كيف تبدو الحركه الان وكيف يتم
التعامل مع المعابر
مرحبا بك المشاهدين بالفعل كان ذكرتي هناك
استمرار في التدفق من خلال المعبرين
الايام الاخيره شاهدت تركيدا شديدا على
معبر قسطل اغلب الذين ياتون من السودان
سواء كانوا من السودانيين او من جنسيات
الاخرى ياتون من معبر كما ذكرتي الاعداد
السودانيين تتجاوز الخمسين الف حتى الان
بحسب ما يعني علمنا من مصادر فاغلب من
يتوجهون الى الحدود المصريه يتجهون مباشره
الى مدينه اسوان حيث احدثت الان يتجهون
بالحافلات من المعابر مباشره الى مدينه
اسوان ومن اسوان يتم اسوان حيث تشهد زخما
كبيرا جدا خلال الايام الاخيره هذه
المدينه بسبب تدفق النسب الكبيره القادمه
من السودانيين مجموعات اخرى تتجه الى
القاهره يعني الحديث دائما مع القادمين من
السودان لربما يعني يتركز حول ما يعانونه
او ما يعانوه خلال هذه الرحله الطويله
سواء هربا من السودان الكل يتحدث بنبره
حزن واسى حول ما راوه حول ما تركوه الكل
ربما يتحدث بنبره قلق حول ما تخفيه قادم
الايام هناك شرائح مختلفه من من
السودانيين القادمين البعض ربما يملك
عقارات او او شقق في القاهره او يدو حتى
بعض المال ليجعله يستمر لفتره قصيره بعد
تخرج ربما
هناك يعني اذا تابعت وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي هناك بعض
الصور التي تشير الى ان مصر تقوم بارجاع
عدد من اللاجئين وانه لا يتم استقبال كل
اللاجئين السودانيين وان هناك اجراءات
صعبه على المعابر في حين تؤكد السلطات في
مصر انها تتعامل مع الامر بجديه شديده وان
هناك فتحه للمعابر وان هناك اجراءات يتم
اتباعها
لضمان دخولهم بامان انقل لنا الصوره اذا
سمحت
انقذ الصوره من حيث ما اسمع نحن نقف
في المعبر سواء في الايام الاولى في ارجين
او حتى من ناحيه ابو سمبل في قسطل فسانقل
في بقى اسمعه حتى من السودانيين بالفعل
هناك عدد من المطلوبه والتي اعلنت عنها
مصر منذ بدايه الازمه ان هذه الاجراءات
لها علاقه بضروره يعني سلامه الاوراق
المطلوبه فهناك من اتى ولم يكن معه
التاشيره فكره الحصول على التاشيره هي
مطلب رئيسي لدخول مصر ومن ممكن ان يكون
هناك رجوع لي الكثير من السودانيين والطلب
منهم بان يكون هناك ضروره الحصول على
التاشيره المصريه من القنصليه في وادي
حلفا القريبه من بعض القرص المفتوحه مصر
تفتح قنصليتها ما زالت مفتوحه في الخرطوم
بالفعل الخرطوم وعدد جميع القنصليات حتى
هناك بيانات لاعاده التمركز تصدرها
الخفاره المصريه او الخارجيه المصريه
باماكن التمركز على القنصليات والخساره
المصريه في الخرطوم وفي عدد من المدن
وبالتالي هناك هذه الاجراءات هي مطلوبه
هناك يعني دخول لكبار السن لاصحاب المرضى
ولكن فيما يتعلق بمن هم ما بين الثمانيه
عشر وبين الخمسين اعمارهم اقصد يعني يجب
ان يكون هناك استفاده لجميع الاوراق فيما
يتعلق بالتاشيره فيما يتعلق بالكشف عن
الهويات فيما يتعلق بالتاكد من سلامه
الاشخاص من الناحيه الجنائيه من الناحيه
بضمان عدم بيكون له اي سجل في اي امور لها
علاقه بالارهاب هناك بالتاكيد هذه الامور
جميعها تستغرق كثير من الوقت وهناك تكدس
كبير في المعبر ولكن نحن جميعا من سجلنا
مع بان بعد هذه الاجراءات يتم التدفق تدفق
بسلاسه من قبل المعبر والتوجه منهم مباشره
الى باقي المدن المصريه شكرا لك زميلي يا
احمد عثمان مراسل العربيه من مدينه اسوان
المصريه على هذا الرصد
هذا ويعرقل القتال بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع في السودان جهود العمل الانساني لا
سيما الوصول الى المناطق المتضرره لمساعده
المحتاجين في بلد كان ثلث سكانه يعانون من
الجوع اساسا قبل الحرب
اغاثه السودان هدف منظمات العمل الانساني
لكن حاله الانفلات الامني المتصاعده منذ
اسابيع تعيق ذلك
صعوبات عده تقف امام منظمات الاغاثه
الدوليه ابرزها احتدام القتال بين طرفي
الصراع رغم الهدن الممتده غياب ضمانات
الامنيه لمسارات قوافذ الاغاثه وصعوبه
تحديد المواقع المتضرره ومن يسيطر عليها
فبين القصف العنيف في العاصمه الخرطوم
ونيران القتال في دارفور تبحث فرق منظمات
الدوليه عن طرق امنه ومسارات تضمن لها
ايصال المساعدات الملحه من الامدادات
الطبيه والغذائيه الى المدنيين العالقين
وبشكل عاجل منظمه اطباء بلا حدود مستوى
العنف الذي سجل في الخرطوم ودارفور ضد
المدنيين ومتطوعي العمل الانساني مقلق اما
عن غياب ضمانات الامنيه فالامم المتحده
ناشدت عده مرات طرفي النزاع من الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع بتوفير ضمانات امنيه
تحمي قوافل المساعدات بعد تكرر عمليات
النهب بشاح في مساعدات الاغاثيه فوفقا
لبرنامج الاغذيه العالمي التابعي للامم
المتحده ان نحو 17 الف طن من المساعدات
الانسانيه اي ما قيمته نحو 14 مليون دولار
تعرضت للنهب منذ اندلاع القتال في السودان
ومن الصعوبات التي تعرقل عمل منظمات
الانسانيه معرفه من من الطرفين المتنازعين
يحكم سيطرته في تلك المنطقه او تلك سواء
في العاصمه الخرطوم او في دارفور غربا
الامر الذي دفع بعض منظمات الاغاثه الى
التوجه الى مدينه بورتسودان التي تشهد
هدوءا نسبيا واستفوضى في اماكن اخرى
بالبلاد لتصبح المدينه نقطه الدخول
لامدادات المساعدات الدوليه ومركزا لعشرات
الالاف الذين يتطلعون الى الفرار من
القتال
ملوك الشيخ العربي
ضع المستشار الالمانيه خلال زيارته لكينيا
الى انهاء الصراع في السودان مؤكدا على ان
الشعب السوداني دفع عن الديمقراطيه لسنوات
لقد دفع الكثير من الناس في السودان عن
الحريه والديمقراطيه لسنوات وغالبا ما
يخاطرون بحياتهم كما دافعوا عن عمليه
الانتقال من الحكم العسكري الى المدني يجب
على الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع انهاء
صراعيهما على السلطه الذي يحدث على حساب
السودانيين ونحن في غايه الامتنان لجهود
دوله كينيا
امتدت تاثيرات الحرب الدائره في السودان
على المغتربين السودانيين في الرياض التي
يجتمع بها اكثرهم يواسي السودانيون بعضهم
البعض في الجلوس معا في المقاهي والجمعيات
ويحاولون معا المساهمه بتخفيف المعاناه عن
الشعب السوداني باي وسيله ممكنه
لم يالفوا حوارات تدور حول قصف وقذائف
تضرب عاصمه بلادهم بخور القهوه الذي
يشاركهم الحديث يدكرهم بالدخان المتصاعد
من ابنيه الخرطوم هكذا انقلبت احوال
الجاليه السودانيه في الرياض من حديث عن
هموم الغربه الى قلق على الوطن
الاوضاع سيئه بالنسبه
فالواحد يعني حزين لكن نسال الله ان ربنا
يسهل الامور ويرفع البلاء عن العباد
والبلاد ان شاء الله لحتى ما قدرنا نعيد
على عيالنا فهمت علي انه الواحد ما قدر
يصل لعياله عن طريق تليفون ولا عن طريق اي
برامج من برامج التواصل الاجتماعي في
الاماكن العامه والاماكن الخاصه يشترك
سودانيون في هذه الايام بالحديث عن الحرب
ولا غير الحرب حديث لم يعتادوا عليه طوال
العقود الماضيه لكنهم قلقون مما يحدث في
الداخل نسيما وان اهاليهم واصدقائهم لا
زالوا في مدن تضربها النيران
كلما طرفت عيني يرف ضياء
وذكريات احبائي اذا خطرت احس بالموج فوق
البحر يلعب
مواساه قد تنطق بها ابيات شعريه وتعبر
عنها نظرات الحضور هنا مشهد القريه حاضر
في صلب الاحاديث اخروا لا يتسمرون امام
الشاشات بحثا عن نهايه لهذا الكابوس
اعتادوا على التكافل الاجتماعي في
جمعياتهم وتقديم الدعم للمغتربين للجدد
لكنهم شرعوا هذه المره في محاوله تقديم
الدعم المادي لقريتهم في شمال السودان
لمساعده اهاليهم الذين نزحوا من الخرطوم
هربا من الحرب
الان في الخرطوم كل التجاره متوقفه يعني
في اي لحظه اذا استمر
الكيلاج ده لمده شهر حتحصل مجاعه داخل
الخرطوم ناس بالذات المغتربين الموجودين
هنا الكاتبهم مع اهلهم هناك ويعني قدروا
يعملوا نوع من النفير على اساس انه يساعده
الاسره العالقه ما قادره ما عندها امكانيه
توصل لاهلها في الشمال الناس يتعاون كل
الجمعيه في حدود اهلها علق الكثير من
المغتربين السودانيين المقيمين في
السعوديه في بدايه الحرب بالخرطوم بعضهم
استطاع العوده من خلال سفن الاجلاء
السعودي
فيما يخطط الكثير ممن التقيناهم هنا لجلب
عائلاتهم الى السعوديه في حال استمرار
الحرب عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه
الرياض
على مر التاريخ وحفاظا على الامن القومي
السوداني كمؤسسه عسكريه حاول الجيش
السوداني دوما الحفاظ على الامن الداخلي
وايضا على الامن الخارجي من خلال الاهتمام
بالقضايا الحدوديه ضمن استراتيجيه عسكريه
محكمه تمكن من خلالها من مواجهه كافه
التحديات والتهديدات الحدوديه المحتمله
تفاصيل اكثر مع زميلي فراس صلواتي دور
حيوي مهم لعبه الجيش السوداني منذ استقلال
البلاد في عام
1956 حيث كان الحفاظ على الاستقرار وتهدئه
الاضطرابات الداخليه ومواجهه التحديات
الحدوديه اولويه قصوى مناطق عسكريه ووحدات
قتاليه بريه ونقاط تفتيش عسكريه تابعه
للجيش السوداني موجوده على طول الحدود
التي تربطه بدول الجوار شمالا هنا حيث
الجار مصر توجد مناطق عسكريه تابعه للجيش
السوداني تحديدا جنوب مثلث حلايب في ولايه
البحر الاحمر كما توجد كاتبه الفرقه
التاسع عشر بمدينه مروي والتي تطل على
طريق شريان الشمال الرابط بين مصر
والسودان على الضفه المقابله مثلث اخر على
الحدود الليبيه السودانيه هناك ايضا قاعده
مركزيه كبيره للجيش السوداني اما غربا
التشاد وبحدود بريه تزيد عن 2000 كيلو متر
مع السودان تنتشر فيها قوات مشتركه بهدف
تامين تلك الحدود فقط
وفي افريقيا الوسطى التي تمزقها الحرب
يوجد الجيش السوداني ضمن نقاط تفتيش
عسكريه عند الدخول والخروج اما على الحدود
السودانيه
يمكن والتي يمكن ان تتحول لقاعده لتدفق
السلاح ينتشر الجيش السوداني ضمن نقاط
تفتيش كبرى
والحدود المتاخمه مع اريتريا ضمن حاميه
عسكريه نقطه صراع هنا وعلى تلك الحدود
المشتعله حينا وحين مع اثيوبيا ينتشر
الجيش السوداني في منطقه الفشقه التي تقع
في ولايه الجضارف وايضا في منطقه الجلابات
وولايه النيل الازرق وفي جنوب البلاد هناك
العديد من المناطق العسكريه ينتشر فيها
الجيش السوداني شمال ابيي شمال ابيي كما
نتابع وكذلك في كوردوفان وولايه النيل
الابيض حدود بريه واسعه يتشاركها السودان
مع دول عديده فرضت على الجيش اتباع
استراتيجيه تحكمها ضوابط عسكريه لحمايه
وتعزيز وجوده على طول الشريط الحدودي
ومن التطورات المشعله في السودان الى ايضا
تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا وهي المشتعله
ايضا
[موسيقى]
اكد وزير خارجيه الروسيه ان الهجوم على
الكرملين كان عملا عدائيا وروسيا سترد
بخطوط وخطوات ملموسه واعتبر ان كييفلن
تحاول مهاجمه الكريم من دون اخطار سادتها
في الغرب حسب وصفه وكشف وزير خارجيه
الروسيه ايضا ان موسكو مساعده للتحدث مع
الغرب وهذا سيحدث عاجلا ام اجلا
من الواضح انه كان عملا عدائيا ومن الواضح
تماما ان ارهابي كيف لم يكن بامكانهم
ارتكاب هذه الحادثه دون علم القياده
الاوكرانيه لن نرد عما اذا كان ذلك سبب
الحرب ام لا لكننا حتما سنرد بالافعال
ونحن لدينا الكثير من الصبر وبالحديث عن
موقف واشنطن لقد اطلعت على بيان وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي
الذي قال فيه ان الولايات المتحده لن تملي
على اوكرانيا ما ينبغي فعله تجاه قيادتها
وهذا يوضح كل شيء
وعلى وقع المعارك في بخمه تحمل رئيس
فاجنرى
قاده الجيش الروسي مسؤوليه سقوط عشرات
الالاف من القتلى والجرحى الروس في
المدينه قبل ذلك حضر رئيس مجموعه باجنار
من ان قوته ستغادر المدينه في العاشر من
مايو الحالي بسبب عدم تامين وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه الذخيره لقوته وقال ان استمرار
القتال في مدينه بخموت من دون ذخيره امر
لا جدوى منه
على وشك الاستيلاء على لكن بعد ان راوا
هذا التقدم اوقف البيروقراطيون شبه
العسكريين توريد الذخيره لمنعنا من القيام
بذلك يعتقدون انهم سوف يدخلون التاريخ
ابلغت وزير الدفاع ورئيس هيئه الاركان
والقائد الاعلى رسميا بان رفاقي لن
يتكبدوا خسائر غير مبرره في بخموت بدون
ذخيره لذا في العشر من مايو سننسحب من
ضخمه
حذيفه عادل مرحبا بك حذيفه العنوان
الرئيسي ربما لساحه الحرب في اوكرانيا هو
التصعيد العسكري الكبير ما هي ملامح هذا
التصعيد هل يمكن رزها
نعم مساء الخير رشا نحن الان في حاله
التاهب الجوي في العاصمه كيف ومعظم ولايات
اوكرانيا هنالك بالفعل الان صواريخ تنطلق
في الجو نحو عده مناطق الان قبل ثواني فقط
اعلنا عمده خركيز ان هنالك صواريخ تتجه
نحو مدينه خاركيف لا يستطيعون ان يحددوا
مكان سقوطها لذلك نصح المواطنين بالبقاء
في الملاجئ لمده 20 دقيقه قادمه كذلك كتب
اندرير ماك الان قبل ثواني فقط على
المواطنين ان لا يتجاهلوا صافرات الانذار
رصد دخان في كييف ولكن ليس في داخل
المدينه وانما في ضواحي المدينه ولكن
رسميا لم تبلغ السلطات عن وصول صاروخ ولكن
لحظه بعض شهود العيان دخان يتصاعد في
الضواحي العاصمه اكيف هنالك انفجار بالفعل
الان فكره قبل حوالي نصف ساعه فقط وهنالك
انفجار اخر في اصل
مدينتين قريبتين جدا مدينتان قريبتان جدا
من حيث القتال يدور الان بشكل عام الجبهه
اليوم تشهد ايضا تصعيد كبير اعلنت ان
نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني عن تفجير
مخازن الذخيره الخاصه بقوات فاجنر في
ضخموت كذلك اليوم كان هنالك احاط اعلاميه
لنتاليا الناطق الرسمي باسم قوات الجنوب
التي قالت انهم يتوقعون تصعيدا كبيرا من
قبل الاتحاد الروسي وهم يرصدون الان السفن
الحربيه في البحر الاسود التي تغير
مواقعها من وقت الى اخر وكذلك هنالك يعني
مزيد من
التعبئه في هذه البواخر وكذلك مزيد من
الصواريخ يتم وصولها الى هذه السفن
الحربيه عفوا وليس البواخر ولذلك هم
يتوقعون في الايام القادمه ان يكون هنالك
تصعيد كبير لذلك تنصح المواطنين ان لا
يتجاهلوا صافرات الانذار من اليوم حتى بعد
التاسع من مايو وهذه الوقت الذي يتوقعون
فيه هذا التصعيد بشكل عام اوكرانيا تنتظر
تصعيد من قبل الاتحاد الروسي بعد ما سموه
بالمسرحيه
والبروباندا الاعلاميه والدعايه الاعلاميه
لتصعيد قادم وهو اتهام كيف بالتفجير الذي
تم او استهداف الكرملين وهم يقولون ان هذا
له ما بعده ان روسيا تحيط امرا وسوف يتضح
هذا الامر في الايام القادمه بشكل عام
ايضا تم تم 60 هجوما في ثلاثه جبهات وهنا
نتحدث عن جبهه بخموت وافديفكا ومارينكا
وكذلك بعض التحركات في اتجاه ليمان ولمان
تدخل بمره اخرى في الصراع بعد ان كانت قد
هدات هذه الجبهه لفتره بعد ان استعاد
وطبعا للعلم فقط لمن هي تقع في ولايه خر
كيف وهي المنطقه التي
بدا منها الهجوم المضاد في العام الماضي
وبالمناسبه طبعا اليوم
من هذا الشهر هو يعني هو ذكرى بدايه
الهجوم المضاد الذي بدا في العام الماضي
واستعاده به اوكرانيا الاراضي في ولايه
خركيف بشكل عام هنالك توقعات للتصعيد على
الصعيد السياسي طبعا اليوم ايضا التقى
الرئيس فلاديمير زيلينسكي بوزير خارجيه
البحرين وهذه الزياره الاولى لرئيس
الدبلوماسيه البحرينيه
منذ بدايه العلاقات بين الدولتين نعم
زميلي حذيفه عادل
اننا الوضع المتصاعد وبشده استعدادا لما
هو هجوم روسي وشيك شكرا لك حذيفه ينضم
الينا ايضا من دونيس كزميل رائد الاغبر
مرحبا بك رائد كيف يبدو معدل سير العمليات
العسكريه في مناطق مختلفه من اوكرانيا
اليوم
تحياتي رشا بالفعل ملفات عديده يمكن طرح
اهمها كيفيه الرد الروسي على الهجوم
الاوكراني هل سيكون استراتيجي ام انه
سيكون على الجبهات ايضا الخلاف ما بين
بريجوجن قائد قوات فاجنر ووزاره الدفاع
الروسيه والتهديد بالانسحاب من مدينه خارق
عفوا كما ان التطور المعارك على الارض
اضافه الى الهجوم المضاد التي تنوي ان
تشنه اوكرانيا على القوات
خلف كبير
في السوق اين تقف وهذا الدمار ناتج عن
ماذا
دعيني انا اتكلم عن تطورات على الارض
والمصور يسلط الضوء على
الدمار الذي خلفه القصف على احد الاسواق
في مدينه دانياس
علم فقط ان القصف لا يتوقف القصف المتبادل
ما بين طرفين الطرف الاوكراني والانفصال
هنا لذلك تسقط وبشكل يومي اعداد كبيره من
القذائف والصواريخ تخلف دمار وقتل
وجرحى لكن لان المشهد اصبح اعتياديا
اصبحنا لا نسلط الضوء عليه حسب
المتطلبات وهو تسليط الضوء على المعارك
لنعد الى الاهم وهو تصريحات بروجن
بالانسحاب من مدينه باخمت المحور الاكثر
سخونه بعد ان سيطر يعني الجيش الروسي او
قوات فاجنر على ما نسبته 90% من الاراضي
في هذه المدينه وبقيه كيلومترين ونصف فقط
السيطره على المدينه قال قائد فاجنير وهو
مستاء من عدم دعم الدفاع الروسيه
لقواته بالاسلحه بانه لا يستطيع اكمال
السيطره رغم انه كان من المفترض ان يعلن
السيطره الكامله في التاسع من مايو ذكرى
النصر على النازيه يعني بعد ثلاثه ايام
لكن اعلن انه سيسلم المناطق والمواقع التي
سيطر عليها
للجيش الروسي وينسحب من خط الجبهه ويتمركز
في المواقع الخلفيه لان ليس لديه ذخائر
تكفي لاكمال المعارك وكان جدا مستاء يعني
المشاهد التي كانت خلفه في الصوره القتلى
من الجنود الروس كانت فظيعه جدا حتى ان
شاشتنا لم تعرضها ايضا هناك معارك في
المحور الجنوبي رشا لا تقل اهميه المعارك
دانيت حيث ان
القوات الاوكرانيه بالفعل يعني تعد لهجوم
مضاد في مدينتي او مقاطعتي خرسون وزبروجه
تقول السلطات في ان القوات الاوكرانيه
زادت منسوب المياه في سد كخوفكا
المتاخم للمحطه النوويه من اجل ان تفيض
المياه من نهر دنيبرو وتغرق المنطقه
وتستطيع القوات الاوكرانيه العوده
والسيطره على المحطه النوويه وان تكون هذه
المياه قد اغرقت الطرق وجعلت الطرق موحله
جدا لتمنع القوات الروسيه من التقدم
وحمايه المحطه النوويه كما ان مدينه خرسون
قال فيها المسؤولون الموالون لروسيا بان
القوات الاوكرانيه تحشد كميات كبيره اعداد
كبيره من الجنود من اجل الانقضاض على
الضفه الشماليه التي يتمركز فيها الجيش
الروسي
نعم رائد اشكرك على كل هذا الرصد لمحاور
مختلفه من خطوط المواجهه في دانيس ك زميلي
رائد الاغبر شكرا لك
هذا وتحفظ الناطق باسم الكرملين عن
الاجابه عن سؤال صحفي حول اخر تصريح
لرئيسي مرتزقه باجنر الذي قال ان هناك
تراجع في بغداد
طبعا شاهدنا ذلك في وسائل الاعلام لكن لا
يمكنني التعليق لان الامر يتعلق بالعمليه
العسكريه الخاصه
قصف جبهه انزاح التعبير
رشا والاساده المشاهدين هذا ليستبعد
احتمال ان يكون كلام رئيس مجنر بمسافه
تضليل او خداعه بالنسبه للجيش الاوكراني
الذي يعد العضه لشن هجوم مضاد والهدف ربما
من هذه التصريحات التي تتكرر من حين الى
اخر خلق انطباعه وكان لدى روسيا نقص
للذخيره وعموما في مشاكل لا تصطدم بها
القوات الروسيه ليس فقط قوات بغداد ووضع
تماما ان يعني مثل هذه
المحاولات لتضليل العدو او الخصم او
الجانب الاوكراني ربما تاتي الان وتتزامن
بالمناسبه مع اجتماع مجلس الامن القومي
برئاسه الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
اليوم حيث يعتقد بان هذا الموضوع مطروح
على اجهزه هذا الاجتماع وطبعا سوف يتخذ
قرار ما حول هذه المشكله ولكن اعود فاكرر
انه ربما وراء مثل هذه التصريحات محاوله
لتضليل الجانب الاوكراني وخلق انتباه بان
هناك بالفئه المشاكل تواجهها قوات هل يعني
هذا ان هذا اتفاق ما بين رئيس فاجنر وما
بين القياده الروسيه على تصدير هذه الصوره
هكذا نفهم
اخذوا الاحتمالات يعني كما قلت وارده ولكن
مع ذلك واضح تماما اذا كان يعني
في مثل هذه الانتقادات اللازعه المواجهه
الى قياده الجيش فالامر يتطلب تدخل مباشرا
من قبل رئيس الدوله فهو وحده كما يعتقد
الكثيرون بامكانه ان يحل هذه المشكله
ويعمل على المزيد من التنسيق بين قوات
فاكتر وقوات
القوات للجيش النظامي ولكن ربما هناك جانب
اخر لهذه المشكله وهي ان السيطره على بخمه
تبدو الان قريبه حتى
بريكوزن اعترف بانه كانت هناك مهمه مطروحه
امامهم امام قوته بالاستيلاء او السيطره
على هذه المدينه مدينه بخموت قبل حلول
عيد التاسعه من ماي وهو عيد النصر وحادث
رمزي بالنسبه لروسيا وكان من الطبيعي ان
تطرح مثل هذه المهمه
الكل يتساءل منذ الهجوم بالمسيرات على
الكرملين كما قالت موسكو ما هي الخطوه
التاليه لبوتين
الخطوه التاليه لبوتين دراهم ربما من خلال
خطابه او كلماته في اثناء العيد عيد النصر
وهذا الخطاب يعتبر امرا تقليديا يعني
يلقيه رئيس الدوله كل عام لمناسبه هذا
العيد وربما سوف يتطرق الى هذا الموضوع او
على الاقل ربما يلمح الى امكانيه اتخاذه
خطوات جوابيه من قبل روسيا ولكن من جانب
اخر رد موسكو يجب ان يكون المفاجئا والا
لفائده منه كما يقول الخبراء العسكريون ما
الذي يعنيه تلميح اليوم بان التفاوض سيتم
عاجلا ام اجلا
هذا التلميح يدل على ان الباب ما زال
مفتوحا من قبل موسكو وهناك مثلا قنوات
اتصال خط ساخن بين موسكو و واشنطن لتجنب
ما هو الاسود في الامر وهو نشوب
نوويه الامر الذي سيعني ماساه كبيره تخيم
على البشريه باسرها وبالتالي روسيا تترك
مجالا للحوار حتى مع الاعداء التي الاعداء
لها منها الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا ودول
الناتو ولكن بشرط ان يؤخذ بعين الاعتبار
القضايا الامنيه التي تقلق روسيا منذ زمن
موسكو تحياتي سيدي
الى ذلك قال مصدر امني مطلع ان جهاز الامن
الفيدرالي الروسيه قد تمكن من منع اعتداء
ارهابي من قبل عملاء المخابرات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه ضد احد مدير محطه زبالوجيا
النوويه ووفقا لمعطيات الامن الفيدرالي
الروسي تم تنسيق هذا النشاط الاجرامي
باشراف مباشر من المخابرات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه او من خلال وسيط في فنلندا
واشار المصدر الى مصادره عبوه ناسفه وكذلك
عده بنادق حربيه اليه وبعض المواد
المتفجره من المخابرات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه
اعلنت ايران ان اربعه دبلوماسيين من
اذربيجان بينهم اثنان من سفاره اذربيجان
في طهران واثنين من القنصليه العامه في
تبريز عناصر غير مرغوبه بها للبقاء على
الاراضي الايرانيه وياتي اعلان طهران بعد
الهجوم الذي وقع في سفاره اذربيجان في
العاصمه الايرانيه واعلان باكو عن طردي
اربعه مواطفين بصفاره الايرانيه في باكو
باعتبارهم عناصر غير مرغوب بها
بعد اقتتام الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي
زياره استمرت اليومين الى دمشق رحب بيان
مشترك لسوريا وايران بالتطورات السياسيه
الاخيره الايجابيه التي تشهدها المنطقه
خاصه فيما يتعلق بتواصل سوريا البناء مع
الدول العربيه وكذلك الاتفاق الايراني
السعودي حيث اكد البيان ان السئنف
العلاقات بين الرياض وطيران بواسطه صينيه
في مارس الماضي يشكل خطوه مهمه نحو مزيد
من التطورات الايجابيه التي تخدم استقرار
الشرق الاوسط وشدد البيان المشترك على
ضروره تضامن والتماسك بين دول المنطقه
لمواجهه التحديات وتوفير الامن والهدوء
عبر التعاون الاقليمي كما اعرب الجانبان
عن استعدادهما لتطوير العلاقات التجاريه
والاقتصاديه مركزين على سبل تطوير التعاون
القائم بينهما فيما يتعلق باعاده اعمار
سوريا
اعلن المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان في بيان
عن مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص من بينهم قياديون في
وحدات الدفاع الذاتي التابعه لقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وذلك في هجوم من قبل طائره
مسيره تركيا بريف الحسكه وقال المرصد ان
المسيره التركيه استهدفت سياره عسكريه تقل
العناصر الثلاثه في قريه قروان بمنطقه تل
الحميس شمال شرق الحسكه
شاركت الجاليه التركيه في المانيا في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه واقترع
الالاف لمرشحهم المفضل طوال الايام
الماضيه ويحق لمليون ونصف المليون تركي
يعيشون في المانيا التصويت في الانتخابات
قرابه المليون ونصف المليون تركي يعيشون
في المانيا يحق لهم المشاركه بالانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه وهنا امام القنصليه
التركيه في برلين صفوف طويله من الناخبين
يصطفون للادلاء بصوتهم اصوات الاتراك في
المانيا تذهب بمعظمها بحسب اتجاهات
التصويت في السنوات الماضيه للرئيس الحالي
رجب طيب اردوغان ومع ذلك هذه المره كانت
المعارضه حاضره هنا وان بصوره خجوله معظم
الاتراك في المانيا الذين قدموا بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه كانوا مهاجرين عمال
ومكثوا هنا كثيرون منهم ما زالوا يشعرون
بارتباط قوي مع تركيا وكثيرون ايضا خاصه
الكبرى في السن لا يحملون الجنسيه
الالمانيه حتى
اردوغان لديه صوره القائد القوي الذي
يمكنه ان يواجه الغرب والاتراك الذين
يعيشون في المانيا يحبون هذه الصوره وكذلك
هم لا يتاذون من الوضع الاقتصادي في تركيا
الواصلون الجدد الى المانيا من المعارضين
السياسيين مثل حسين دمير واوزان البيرق
الذين لجاوا بعد الانقلاب الفشل ياملون ان
تحمل الانتخابات في تركيا تغييرا قد ينعكس
عليهم
امل ان تفوز المعارضه فهم وعدوا بانهم
سيحترمون حقوق الانسان ويعيدون العمل
بالقانون وهذا يعني ان كل الاتهامات
الباطله سيتم رفعها وسيصبح القضاء مستقلا
اصوات الاتراك في الخارج تشكل قرابه
الثلاثه نصفهم يصوتون في المانيا ما يعني
ان اصوات الاتراك هنا قد تحدث فرقا في حال
كان الاقبال مرتفعا وهو ما يبدو الحال
عليه هذا العام راغده بهنام العربيه برلين
ونعود مشاهدينا لمتابعه التطورات السياسيه
المتلاحقه في السودان مبعوث البرهان يقول
انه سيسافر وفد من الجيش السوداني الى
مدينه جده السعوديه لمناقشه المبادره
السعوديه الامريكيه ويشير ايضا الى انه لم
يتخذ قرار حتى اللحظه بلقاء مباشر او حوار
مباشر مع قوات الدعم السريع ولكنه يؤكد ان
هناك وفد سوداني سيسافر الى مدينه جده
السعوديه لمناقشه المبادره السعوديه
الامريكيه لوقف اطلاق النار سجل حزب
المحافظين البريطاني الذي يحكم الولاد منذ
13 عاما نتائج اوليه سيئه في الانتخابات
المحليه التي جرت في انجلترا امس الخميس
ومني المحافظون بخسائر كبيره في المعاقل
التقليديه لليمين البريطاني في انتخابات
تجديد المجالس البلديه
ويتوقع حزب العمال ان يحرز تقدما كبيرا
بنسبه 8% على الاقل على المحافظين وهو
فارق يرى انه سيترجم بفوز اذا تكرر في
الانتخابات التشريعيه التي تشير استطاعات
الراي الى تقدم واضح جدا للعمال فيها
استكملت السلطات البريطانيه استعدادها
لحفل تتويج الملك تشارليت الثالث وبهذه
المناسبه عاد الحديث عن تكاليف التتويج
وسط الازمه الاقتصاديه التي تمر بها
البلاد اذ تعتبر تكلفه العائله الملكيه
على دافعي الضرائب موضوعا جدليا في
بريطانيا ويزداد هذا الجدل مع اقتراب
المراسم والاحتفالات الملكيه التي تقع
بالكامل بالطبع على الموازنه العامه في
بريطانيا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في يونيو من عام
1953 توجت الملكه اليزابيث الراحله في حفل
كلفه نحو 50 مليون جنيه استرليني واليوم
وبعد 70 عاما تقدر تكلفه تتويج ابنها
ب 100 مليون جنيه بحسب لجنه التنظيم
الفاتوره بما فيها التكاليف الامنيه
والحفل الغنائي الضخم في قلعه
تدفعها الحكومه نظرا الى انه حدث دوله
بمعنى ان العب يقع على الموازنه العامه
ودافع الضرائب في ظل ازمه تكلفه معيشه
يعاني منها الملايين
الملك اخذ الوضع الاقتصادي في الاعتبار
وحاول تقليص الفعاليات جزئيا ولكن اعتقد
ان الاغلبيه تؤيد اقامه حفل تتويج مشرف
لان فعاليات التتويج لا تاتي كل سنه او
حتى كل عقد ويجب ان تلتزم بمستوى عال
واحترام للتقاليد والتاريخ
وفي محاوله لمراعاه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
قلل الملك عدد المدعوين الى نحو 2000 مدعو
مقارنه بثمانيه الاف شخص حضروا تتويج
الملك الراحله المراسم الرسميه داخل
الكنيسه واسم ايضا تمت تقليص مدتها من
ثلاث ساعات الى ما بين 90 دقيقه وساعتين
كما خصص الملك يوما يشجع فيه المواطنين
على التطوع والقيام بالاعمال الخيريه في
مجتمعهم للتجديد على اهتمامه بمساعده
الفقراء والمتضررين
الحكومه بدورها تقول ان الحفل سيجلب
مردودا سياحيا ضخما وسيعطي جرعه نشاط
للاقتصاد كما يشير المسؤولون الى حقوق
البث لقنوات حول العالم التي من المتوقع
ان تحصل الملايين من الجنيهات للموازنه
الاخر حفل تتويج كان قبل سبعين عاما فهو
فعليا حدث تاريخي واذا نظرنا الى احتفالات
اليوبيل البلاتينيه السنه الماضيه نقدر
انه جلب ملياري جنيه من الانفاق في
المطاعم والفنادق وفي منطقه الويست اند في
لندن المبيعات الاضافيه بلغت 80 مليون
جنيه ولا يزال جدل يدور حول الاجازه
الرسميه من مؤيد يقول انها ستدعم الاقتصاد
بنحو مليار جنيه من خلال الاستهلاك
والسياحه ومن معرض يحذر من تكلفه توقف
العمل قد تتجاوز مليار جنيه ايا كانت
الفاتوره النهائيه لمراسم التتويج يعد
التحدي الاكبر بالنسبه للعائله الملكيه هو
اقامه احتفال يليق بض خامه هذا الحدث
التاريخي ولكن اخذا في الاعتبار الصعوبه
الاقتصاديه التي يعيشها البريطانيون
كارينا كامل العربيه لندن
هذا والتقى الاميره ويليام وزوجته كاتب
الجمهور المصطفى للسلام على العائله
الملكيه البريطانيه وذلك مع اقتراب
مراسميه يوم غد السبت ولكن من المنتظر ان
يحضرها عدد كبير من زعماء العالم لتتويج
الملك تشارليت الثالث ولي عهد الامير وليم
وتنضم الينا من لندن الزميله ريما مكتبي
مديره مكتب العربيه في لندن مرحبا بك ريما
يعني في بدايه قبل الدخول في مساله الجدل
حول تكاليف هذا الحفل ارصدي لنا ريما كيف
تبدو الاجواء في بريطانيا هذا حدث تاريخي
ولا يحدث كل عام او اعوام او ربما عقود هو
حدث فريد من نوعه تفضل
فعلا فعلا رشا فريد من نوعه انا اقف امام
مبنى مستر ابي وهي الكنيسه التي تشهد على
تقاليد المراسيم التتويج من اكثر من الف
سنه
وبالتالي من القرن الحادي عشر هذه الكنيسه
شهدت مراسم تتويج تاريخ يتحدث كل تفصيل في
يوم
التتويج له قصه له تاريخ لون العباءه او
الثوب الذي سيرتديه الملك الكرسي التي
سيجلس عليها مراحل التتويج القوات المسلحه
اكبر عدد من القوات المسلحه سيكون برفقه
الملك على لحظه خروجه من قصر باكينغهام
اكبر حدث امني واكبر تحدي امني
الجيش والشرطه البريطانيه في عام 2023
حدث قلم سنشهد مثله ورغم كل الجدل الناس
متحمسه هناك احتفالات على مدى الاراضي
البريطانيه يعني شاشات عملاقه تنقل الحدث
بارتيز حفلات في الحدائق والكل يصلي ان
يساعدنا الطقس كل لحظه بيتغير
وستكون لدينا تغطيه خاصه مع زميله ريما
مكتبي وفريق العربيه بالكامل في لندن لهذا
الحدث التاريخي على شاشه العربيه نعود الى
مساله الجدل هو جدل قديم جديد حول التكلفه
التي تتعلق بالعائله الملكيه والى اي مدى
يمثل ذلك ضغطا على الموازنه العامه التي
تواجه تحديات ايضا بحكم التحديات
الاقتصاديه كيف تبدو الساحه الجدليه في
هذا المحور في بريطانيا
الشعبيات الملك تشارلز بشكل عام ارتفعت
جدا منذ كان واليا للعهد عندما اصبح ملك
وعندما نظم مراسم التتويج كان حريصا ان
يكون حفل ليس ضخما يعني اثار ان يكون هناك
ملوك ورؤساء وامراء
ورؤساء دول ولكن ايضا حرص ان تكون تكلفه
من ضمن المعقول قد تصل الى 250 مليون يعني
ربع مليار جنيه استرليني ولكن يقال ايضا
ان تقريبا
مليار وربع ستكون عائدات هذا الحدث طوال
هذا العام من حيث السياحه الداخليه
والخارجيه وما تدر عليه من اموال طالما
كان هذا الموضوع هو موضوع بحث وجدل في
بريطانيا لان العائله الملكيه يعني تكاليف
اي حفل تقيمه ليكون من جيوب دافعيه ضرائب
يعني من جيوب الشعب ولكن ايضا كان دائما
الجدل بان هذه العائله بنفسها هي
البراند نيم او الاسم البراق البريطانيا
من حول العالم نعم ريما هل هناك اي تفاصيل
حول الشخصيات الكبيره التي ستحضر حفل
التتويج زعماء من العالم هل شخصيات دوليه
هل هي تفاصيل حول هذا الامر اما اننا
نتحدث عن حدث سيتم التركيز فيه فقط على
العاصمه البريطانيه لندن
النجم الشاشه سيكون غدا الملك تشارلز
لاشاك حتى الامير هاني تحرس وسائل الاعلام
ان لا يكون مكان الجدل او مكان الاهتمام
لكن سنعرف اللائحه النهائيه غدا من حضر
ومن لم يحضر طبعا كل افراد العائله
الملكيه الحضور بشكل عام 2200 شخص رؤساء
كل دول الكومنويلز ستحاول ان تكون موجوده
اصلا قواتها المسلحه
ممثله على الارض رؤساء امراء من الدول
الدول الحليفه بعض الحضور من العالم
العربي
وايضا يعني الكثير من المشاهير سيكون
حاضرين ولكن دعوات محدده جدا لانه الملك
تشارلز اصر ان لا يتخطى العدد 2200 شخص
وايضا لحصر التكاليف طيب الجمهور في لندن
كيف سيتابع المراسم كيف ستكون الاماكن
المخصصه للجمهور هل هي اماكن قريبه من
الفاعليات لاماكن بعيده الاعتبارات امنيه
نريد ان نعرف بعض التفاصيل حول ما سيحدث
لا شكر شانه اكبر تحدي امنه يعني هذه
الشرطه على الاحصنه الان نراها مباشره على
الهواء تجوب يعني بالطريقه التقليديه
شوارع لندن انا امام قصر
ابي الكنيسه لكن هذا كله سيكون ممنوع على
المره بشكل عام غدا فقط الذين يملكون
تصريحا مسبقا بامكانهم الوقوف هنا الباقي
الشوارع المؤديه الى هنا ستكون
فيها يعني طوق امني مشدد جدا اصلا حتى
المحطه التي تصل الى هذه النقطه مقفله
نتوقع ان يكون وسط لندن ضمن طوق امني شديد
جدا
والباقي سيكون في الحدائق وايضا طبعا نحن
سنقسم معك ريما في هذا الحدث
سننتظر منك ومن الزملاء الصور المميزه في
تغطيه العربيه من امام ويسترن مستر ابي
زميله ريما مكتبي
استعداد لحفل تتويج الملك تشارل ذات تغطيه
مستمره بعد قليل زميلي ابراهيم بدر على
راس الساعه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات